this was the scene just days ago at the
leipzig book fair it's the second
largest trade fair of its kind in
germany and a platform for publishing
houses to present their star authors but
this woman came here without a publisher
poppy j anderson is a self-publisher who
sold 250,000 copies of her ebook in 15
months today she's meeting her fans for
the first time chapter Duffman a massage
I'd be happy if 50 people read the book
in the first year I never expected this
a lot of people have gone her readers
are almost exclusively women
he had she has an easy going riding
style you can laugh you can cry from the
first word to the last you can really
relate to them a playing field in the
West German city of essen the novelist
spent a lot of time here as a teenager
over the years she created a fantasy
world for herself involving an American
football team let's was I was around 12
I asked for a typewriter for Christmas
and then I just started hitting the keys
though the 31 year old says she
basically rights for herself she still
welcomes feedback so self-publishing
seemed like a perfect opportunity
pattinson suave in 2012 I saw a report
from the Frankfurt Book Fair on self
publishing which I'd never heard of
before when I thought it was really
interesting because you can publish
something without risking anything
without needing an agent or a publisher
a photo from vision come using the
pseudonym poppy j anderson she uploaded
her first romance novel to an internet
platform and within two months the book
wound up in the top 100 of the e-book
charts her first novel became an
internet bestseller at 299 for copies
captain Emes queda I never would have
thought that something like this could
happen pasion continuity sang
the novelist is working on her doctoral
dissertation in international relations
but alongside her academic work she
increasingly becomes romance novelist
poppy j anderson the internet platform
she uses is responsible for the business
side of things the author gets up to
seventy percent of the profits and her
initial romance novel has turned into an
eight-part series as a sunny finish had
when it started doing well and I was
getting very good feedback I wanted more
people to be able to read it and I wrote
to publishers and from a lot of them i
heard things like it's an American story
about football players what did German
women have to do with football players
and a plot set in New York City Daniel
Kash doc I'm foxit one other writers
face similar hurdles Berlin thriller
author nickel ooh [ __ ] couldn't find a
publisher for her novel the seventh day
so she tried her luck with Internet
self-publishing the novel immediately
shot to number one on the ebook
bestseller list selling more than a
hundred thousand copies then there's
self-publisher you anna safina whose
crime novel series berlin gothic spent
sixty six days at number one on the
germany book charts longer than any
traditionally published book has ever
done Rodham determined with the literary
side especially we see that
self-publishing allows works to emerge
that our to Barb Tunisia oriented too
ambitious for traditional publishers
position sistema each year some 90,000
new books are released in germany but
thanks to self-publishing that number is
set to double within a few years but
does the trend mean quantity over
quality but his ins and it admitted what
we're seeing are established stars were
switching from the traditional
publishing system to self-publishing
because that way they have more creative
freedom the process goes more quickly
and the profit margin is more appealing
I don't believe that self-publishing
means that the quality will
systematically rise or fall I think that
more readers will simply be able to read
what they want to
like for instance papi J Anderson's
books traditional publishers have seen
the writing on the wall after that it
feels fantastic the idea that I can go
into a bookshop and my book is lying
there as a physical printed book that's
a great feeling a major German publisher
will be releasing her first three ebooks
as paperbacks starting this autumn